welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to with the childsplay reboot just
around the corner we've had numerous
fans who've managed to get lucky with
Chucky and see the film early at test
screenings many of them have been unable
to hold it all in and have taken to the
Internet to provide us with a pretty
extensive plot summary for the entire
movie throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film as well as its
ending I've compiled these from numerous
sources and though you should always
take leaks like this with a pinch of
salt they seem pretty accurate from here
on out its full spoilers ahead so if you
don't want to have the thumb potentially
ruined for you then I highly recommend
that you turn off now we've seen with my
Avengers end game and Game of Thrones
leaked videos that the sources I use
tend to be 100 percent accurate so this
is your last chance to turn off the
video before you ruin the movie without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video I hope you
enjoy it now sit back relax and let's
get into my child's play plot breakdown
okay so whilst this is the remake I'll
be predominantly using clips from the
original movie just to illustrate my
points and because the new Chucky doll
looks like the Matt Damon puppet from
Team America anyway the movie opens in
Vietnam where a factory worker that
haters boss disables the security
restrictions on the company's new
top-of-the-line toy named Buddy in a
polar opposite to the original movie
buddy is an AI doll that's basically a
walking talking Alexa with a tasteful
murder you've had rumors that the food
ooh possession curse from the original
movie would not be appearing in this
film and now we can confirm this however
there is some ambiguity around this as
the factory worker kills themselves by
jumping out of a window upon shipping
the doll which could be interpreted as
the passing of their vengeful spirit
into the toys buddy is expensive and by
the time Andy gets him he's basically
old news with buddy too scheduled for
release in the not-too far distant
future Andy's mom can only afford buddy
even though he wants buddy to but the
boy still plays were there and tries to
name a time
solo however buddy just wants to be
called Chucky and after inquiring at the
store where she works Andy's mom played
by Aubrey Plaza is told that the
previous owner must have called it
Chucky
anyway Chucky is glitchy and stutters a
lot a mark hamill who voices it
apparently uses his full range when
playing the character and it's a fun
watch now this is where things get
complicated as I think this plot point
will anger a lot of diehard fans
apparently Chucky wants to kill Andy not
because he's got a murderous personality
but just because Andy doesn't really
want to play with him and his after a
buddy to feeling neglected he goes on a
rampage and due to the worker and the
factory making changes it has no
restrictions on its behavior
Chucky goes while and kills a handful of
people and the finale of the film takes
place a kazlaw place with Chucky
activating some newly delivered body two
dolls which all go on a rampage
he has Andy's mom tied up for some
reason though I don't know why he didn't
kill her
but it looks like he's about to go on a
murder spree at this point in the film
Andy has convinced his friends about the
doll and similar to the ending of it
chapter one they wail on it beating it
over and over the doll is defeated and
the movie ends with the CEO of the
company staying that it was a one-off
glitch and that they had nothing to do
with the doll acting the way it did the
film ends with bunny 2 being launched
and there are hints that Chucky has
managed to inhabit one of these dolls
after activating them during the final
fight and that's apparently the entire
plot breakdown of the film as it will be
released come June 21st personally I
think it sounds a bit lackluster with
the story being pretty predictable and
so similar to the original bother AI
stuff that it doesn't really strike me
as something that will be spectacular I
love all brie Plaza and Mark Hamill
though and if anyone can sell this movie
it'll be them obviously just because
something is by-the-numbers doesn't mean
that it's bad and there's plenty of
films such as say John wick and search
that are pretty predictable but still a
lot of fun so I am looking forward to it
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
in the movie and if you think that these
leaks are correct are you happy with
what you've heard so far
do you think this needs to be
reassembled comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my spider-man far from home lick pop
breakdown which would be linked at the
end we've also just launched a merge
section on the channel so if you'd like
to support the show and get something
back from it make sure you click the
links in the boxes below this is the
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]